y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace algunos años cuando especial a
tomar un poquito más en serio desde el
corte para quedarme con hacer alguna
carrera defensiva empecé a entender que
no todos son aspectos físicos técnicos
tácticos incluso sabiendo lo difícil que
voy a llegar a ser la ciudad un lugar
donde están las mejores condiciones y
hay un camino marcado por dónde
transitar
desde ese momento
y empecé a ver situaciones y
experiencias que iban pasando e intentar
transformar las palabras en palabras que
yo sentía que debía conocer su
significado pero desde el punto de vista
frío de una definición de diccionario
sobre el punto de vista práctico ser uno
con esa palabra internalizar las
y esas palabras me gusta llamarlas
motoras palabras que me van a dar noción
y conciencia de que estoy transitando y
viviendo en ese momento y ahora la
fuerza y muchas veces que hace falta
para poder conservar
supongo el contexto de un gimnasio ya se
está entrenando habitualmente y estamos
en proceso de aprender un ejercicio
nuevo
el aparato era la barra fija
realidad a casi tres metros de altura
precisamente dos metros 80 y el
ejercicio que estamos haciendo consistía
en tomar impulso girando siempre
subjetiva sólo de la mano infante iba a
ser objetos textos muy puntuales y
precisos soltarlos volar
colar por nosotros efímeros pero
intensos segundos flotar
y podría tomarla
en este momento nuestro aprendizaje de
ejercicio consiste en hacer todo
esto organizado vamos a la competencia
una vez estamos ahí
es grande una posible caída de muchas
y organizado llega el momento
eso
más hay mucha inseguridad tensiones
y hacer
[Música]
de farmacia
y encontró los propios grupos de chicos
info
disuelto la barra
y capas en egipto que tengo que hacer
para qué
y después de unos segundos ya que el
color
ya estoy en el momento que tanto he
esperado y que ahora
igual
dijo que todas esas sensaciones que
sentí de temor e inseguridad se apoderó
de mí me bloqueé no me deje seguir hacia
lo que yo quería conseguir presente tras
estar volando o lo intentó capaz de
cargo de mapas no sale como espero y
hasta me golpeó pero voy a tener uno
utilizando de lo que dice que va a
permitir corregir para la siguiente
pasado en este caso voy estar
aprendiendo
a continuar y todas esas palabras esas
emociones en ti se resume en una sola
que fue miedo
sonido de las teclas de golpear de creer
que no estaba a la altura
y en ese momento entendí que yo quería
progresado avanzar del deporte y
aprender a convivir con
a veces
pero claro todas estas emociones y
sensaciones que se van a disfrutar como
por arte de magia sino que necesitan de
otra palabra motora
y segunda a la que podemos definir como
la capacidad humana de decidir sobre
nuestra propia conducta lo que todos
conocemos como voluntad
[Música]
la que estamos hablando de deporte
viento ejercicio
trabajamos estimulamos exigimos paso a
fortalecer
exigimos consentir a otros diaria de
visitarnos
aquí no le ha pasado nunca de alguna vez
proponerse hacer algo
y que con el barça decimos energía es
entusiasmo se va ya tanto y se va
desapareciendo
yo es básico no estamos enfocados
la motivación ese músculo llamado
voluntad de trabajar
porque hacia dónde quiero ir y los
hechos son falta de sincronía entonces
ese camino que vamos a recorrer hacer un
camino
a continuación un poquito
debe ser más fuerza para compensar la
falta de motivación
a una resistencia mucho mayor y es allí
donde va a surgir
cuántas una situación que a mí me pasa
un cuento este despojo que también es
llegar a casa
una película de la serie que termina
tarde o temprano estudiando a trabajar o
entrenar
tengo que alcanzar
y una estabilidad
música
y todas esas sensaciones esos mensajes
pensaba
quizás nueva energía con una semana o en
un mes pero está fortaleciendo esa
voluntad
el cual keiko que tenemos un objetivo a
largo plazo tenemos different
de alcanzar
para que una mayor fuerza verdad que
estemos
pequeñas
hay una inversión hace mucho de tender a
deportes y la visualización está que le
contaba al principio donde nos
imaginamos nosotros haciendo un
ejercicio que sirve mucho para corregir
internalizar sensaciones
y las hacemos en primera persona y vamos
ver nosotros lo que estaríamos y cómo
estaríamos haciendo los mismos ojos en
ese momento o de tercera persona que
nosotros seríamos nuestros mismos
espectadores
la exención que a mí más me gusta hacer
es la de imaginarme después del torneo
cuando termina un material científico de
lentas
si usted está contento satisfecho
tranquilo la tranquilidad de que cada
paso que diste en ese momento para
llegar ese día
fue fructífera fue estuvo alto de las
circunstancias que cada pequeño
sacrificio que hiciste en ese proceso
valió la pena
y si a ese sacrificio también no puedo
dejar de mencionar tercer palabra motor
que va muy de la mano está
tiene que ver mucho con la
satisfacciones en cada esfuerzo que
hacemos
así que cada pequeña pequeña
satisfacción que tengamos valga
de palabra
podríamos es indispensable también
podríamos decir que es esa capacidad que
tenemos esa actitud de saber tolerar o
esperar lo que desborda de azúcar pero
tolerar la y esperar con cierta
fortaleza
esta paciencia
y la paciencia
muchas veces nosotros en los procesos
tenemos que
son carreras de 100 metros
desesperado por llegar a esa meta pero
eso son más de 42 meses no va a pasar un
montón de cosas mucho más profundas que
van a enseñar más que el mismo hecho de
llegar a navidad
caso personal que tuve hace un par de
años así cuatro años
bueno desafortunado pero afortunado
de todo lo que hacía todos los días un
golpe muy fuerte muy duro y
desafortunado por el compuesto de un
momento en el que estamos a días de
dejar un panamericano de mes y medio el
mundial de son dos de las competencias
quizás más importantes que tenemos
y digo que afortunadamente porque sin
ser sin saberlo y sin quererlo que
también enseñando muchas más cosas
me mostró por ejemplo me presento gente
médicos kinesiólogos profesores
excelentes en esta desgracia me demostró
un fin están conmigo del primer momento
acompañando para que no decaiga
y a la vez me permitió darme cuenta de
cuánto me gustaba el yo yo estaba
haciendo estaba disfrutando
también dentro de la vorágine de las
competencias los viajes de los
entrenamientos
la rutina en la que afloran a veces son
las que más temprano no tengo tiempo
y que casi fijas y que en realidad están
sacando el foco y enloquecido entonces
el hecho de querer volver a estar yo
creo que esas ganas y esa sensación de
querer tener una revancha
sin definidos durante todo el tiempo
somos eso estamos haciendo somos un
proceso
errores que tenemos dolores varias pero
específicas con satisfacción
valga la pena
pero yo porque ha habido demasiadas
cosas y varias pero no tantas como las
que me faltan pero también es porque lo
veo mucho en las personas que no quieren
en mis hermanos mis padres en los amigos
y es ahí donde está criticando tiene
sacrificio y cada vez me esfuerzo
también por ellos
y como digo qué pasa en el deporte
pasa la vida
refiero a que estas tres palabras
personas me ayudaron mucho no sólo se
limitan a un contexto de una pileta de
natación de una calle
gimnasia para más allá de todo el tiempo
están con nosotros de que nos levantamos
hasta que nos acostamos y entramos a un
aula hasta que salimos
desde que intentamos nos proponemos
llegar a un título universitario desde
un proponerse alcanzar un trabajo
pero podemos percibir nuestros sueños
[Música]
probamos personas simplemente siempre
que nos proponemos en ese momento
empezamos a crecer
y claro crecer hacer algo nuevo no va a
generar miedo
pero vamos a necesitar para poder
superar
sin miedos vamos a callar desafío
y vamos a dar cuenta que la paciencia la
vamos a tener que extremar porque si no
no vamos a llegar a esos objetivos
y digo que también creo que tenemos una
voluntad inquebrantable
yo la descubrimos siendo la exigimos en
nosotros mismos muy difícil que podamos
y si de algo nosotros tenemos que lugar
y de esos límites
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]